but of all the dedicated fan bases out
there that house for me to watch their
show every season I've got to give it to
the symphony fan base for their
perseverance every month it's gig ugh
have you watched him for gear yet gig ik
watched synfig year and Here I am
looking at the summer chart thinking how
the hell does this have five seasons so
you know what sim forgive fans I hear
you
maybe this time I'll actually give it
the attention you desire oh my god this
is incredible
there's at least a guy with a mop this
season
[Music]
what are you doing watching porn
oh thank god I thought you were watching
anime be honest if you hear of an anime
being about five high school girls get
curious and interested in sex your first
thought is ah [ __ ] here we go again
anime the return of I can't believe it's
not hentai but actually this is a teen
sex comedy drama for Mario coda of Ana
Hana and Maggie no a Sakura Fame it
deals with a group of girls reaching
that age where puberty is hitting like a
and you're losing your childhood
innocence so you first discover and get
curious about sex losing your virginity
[ __ ] hand jobs and who knows maybe
even a bit of premarital hand-holding
it's awkward it's relatable and honestly
it's laugh-out-loud funny this is one of
the most under watched anime this season
so I don't know how can sum it up easily
to get more people to watch oh my god
this is just mo a American Pie jørgen
understand that about me Dominic judo uh
yes a woman of culture
[Music]
look at this trihard pansy all right
time to see what actual peak performance
looks like I'm actually convinced there
is nothing more powerful in this world
than cute anime girls Kay on got people
to pick up an instrument a place further
than the universe made you want to
travel Yuri cam got you to sleep in the
outdoors and now after years of avoiding
the gym I suddenly want to get my unfit
ass into shape because I saw some cute
anime girls working out can we just
replace the entire school curriculum
with cute anime girls doing stuff at
this point because I don't know how this
can be so motivational entertaining and
teach me important fitness lessons too
like lesson number one never skip face
day I'm Bear Grylls and today we're
gonna look at some of the top survival
movies and figure out just how realistic
the routine - girl this brings back good
memories but the thing is it totally
works I mean I've done that and the
Sahara were they with a camel and we've
gone from cue girls doing small things
to cute girls doing each other on an
island I mean cute girls do desert
island survival and each other look
think what you will but this is a
serious educational Survival show and I
mean if you can't learn things while
watching 1 or 2 or 4 anime girls letting
out in a permanent beach episode then
really what's the point
speaking of survival anime we've got
another one an Astra lost in space which
I'm told has a very similar plot to the
Netflix series lost in space and also
the 1998 feature film lost in space
oh and not forgetting the 1965 series
lost in space I think it's about people
that get transported to another world or
something
all right now of [ __ ] talking dr.
Stein was one of the most hype new
shounen jump manga and I can totally see
why it sets 3,700 years in the future
after the entire world was turned to
stone which
because the main character sanku kept
track of it by taking the mr. beast
challenge to the next level known 4041
over data for dinner with a 1404 hornet
of what humanity has regressed of the
Stone Age and through the knowledge of
science they find a way to survive and
aim to bring modern civilization back
and the first step to surviving in the
stone world is to drink my own pee I
really like this one you know forgetting
that this is just basically shown in
primitive technology it's a very
interesting concept that I haven't seen
in anime it revolves around gaming
technology way more advanced than the
current environment should allow for yes
the power system is essentially just
basic science yes science the only thing
that be warded me was how I've really
carefully set up its rules as a
realistic world of science here's a
world where knowledge can overcome the
trials of nature you too can do exactly
the same time if we follow our steps
that's how much thoughts we put into it
oh and by the way here's a Joe Joe
character yes science and now for modern
anime in a nutshell got transported to
another world you know I would call this
a running joke if it was actually funny
yes Eastlake I hasn't died yet and yes
we've somehow gotten Maury Sakai this
season than ever before at this point
you already know if you're Issei Chi
trash and are immune to the repetition
or if you just phase it out and move on
so my fellow ISA Chi trash man let's get
ready to jump back into the genre once
again this is honestly the edgiest [ __ ]
I've seen in a while and you know what I
know it's bad but this is the premium
Issei Chi junk food I [ __ ] eat up I
heard this is completely butchering the
source material but honestly no matter
how poorly this may be adapting it I
can't see the edge going away in any
form wait a minute completely butchered
adaptation vampires
powering up by eating monsters our
protagonist who literally turns his hair
gray with the power of edge this is just
Tokyo ghoul in another world
right there bees remember when I said
last season that Ken Jenna Margo had
reached new heights of generic nurse
well he say Kai cheap magician
apparently led to that and went can I
copy your homework yeah sure just change
it up so it doesn't look obvious like
copied right oh no you can literally
just copy it wait
what does he say Kai trash I've just
come to accept their the true meaning of
that is being able to watch the same
show every season and still be
entertained because at this point I
count this as a rewatch all right people
we're starting to run out of ideas for
Easter guy and people are starting to
notice is there anywhere left for this
genre to go I've got it milf Issei Kai
milf Sakai that's the answer
milf Sekai milf Sekai milf sack I milk I
milk I car I don't know what it says
about this genre when the most original
Issei Kai the season is one where a mum
gets transported into a game with her
son though is milf tastic as this mum is
I can't help but get turned off by her
complete lack of parenting skills to
raise this [ __ ] of a kid you can't
talk to you like that
I mean for [ __ ] sake give him a
spanking teach him some discipline just
get him [ __ ] vaccinated already cuz
their relationship is literally why
don't you go across the street and buy
some condoms because we should at least
be safe if you're gonna suck me Mom you
might as well go buy some cigarettes too
because I'd like to have a smoke after I
get good [ __ ] you wanna [ __ ] me mum Joe
look if you're watching this you already
know the reason you're watching this
let's not beat around the bush you're
looking for a bit of hada utter in your
life and there ain't anything wrong with
that we don't judge here as my man
cocoon likes to say the right ara ara
makes the D go
ah yeah it's time to fight fire with
fire and guns whoa honestly I do feel a
bit for fire force first Pro mess steals
its thunder robbing it of the label of
first big firefighter anime and then of
course there's the unfortunate
coincidence that the subject matter
attack caused is uncomfortably similar
to recent tragic events which is a shame
because if you're able to remove all
that and view it in its own bubble it's
one of the best anime this season coming
from the crater of soul eater this show
looks fantastic if you told me bones had
continued their work from Soul Eater to
this I would have totally believed you
but this isn't bones it's David
production and it's easily the best
looking thing they've made sorry ok oh
god I'm so sorry what surprised me even
more is how much heart it has I expected
your typical Shonen with fantastic
looking action scenes but I didn't
expect how touching a lot of these
opening stories would be it's been a
whole mixed bag of great surprises and
I'm looking forward to seeing where
it'll go
coming right of the heels of a very
disappointing third season of index
we've got accelerator continuing the
trend of tomorrow spin-offs being
superior to the mainline anime series
and how can it not with best boy leading
the series it just breaks my heart with
all the Yi Sakai airing the season this
is the only gig truck who has gotten
wait that's illegal and now this has a
fantasy character he's been transported
to our well so it's like a reverse Issei
Chi yaar kissy oh and we're back to e
sekai wait a minute this isn't me sake i
what is this ah Fanta say is that what
they're calling Issei Kyle this ISA car
nowadays you know I would be more
excited for done much he season to you
but it's been so long and so many
fantasy dungeon calling RPG type enemies
have come out since then but I barely
remember anything that happened but can
we just appreciate for a moment that
this first arc essentially revolves
around a war that got started because
someone insulted a waifu it's a literal
waifu war playing in a rock band two
feet apart cuz they're totally gay
honestly this is actually pretty good cg
hands aside the bound for missus look
and sounds great the boys are all
likable and it seems like a proper god
damn music anime which is totally my jam
but from this point on can we just all
agree to call it by its proper name gay
on remember this Wimpy Kid well ever
wonder what he'd look like if he was old
our daddy well looks like we got another
faint spin-off to add to the meagre list
of fake stuff out there honestly though
you can even enjoy this even if you're
not a fake fan it's just CSI London with
magic where the gang solves a different
murder case every week and hey there's
no Holy Grail war so we don't have
another Sabre clone out of the
ridiculously large pile
oh crap
well one of us is gonna have to change
there are a handful of manga that are up
there in legendary status that have
never been adapted and until this season
finland saga was one of them
this stands as one of the most
critically acclaimed seinen manga of all
time and i'm happy to say that studio
wits seemed to be giving it the amazing
treatment it deserves of course
everyone's going to point at the big
fight scenes but equal care and
attention has been given to the beat for
quieter scenes and if you listen really
carefully they added a really nice touch
you can just about hear the salty tears
of berserk and Kingdom fans it's not a
series that will explode onto the scene
but gradually build itself up into a
master class of storytelling I can't
even begin to fit the many layers of
this tale into a short paragraph but
this first arc in Finland saga to me is
right up there with the Golden Age art
from berserk and if this adaptation
continues this quality it'll easily be
contender for anime of the year day 1000
of the ISA Kai invasion I can't tell
what is ISA Kai and what isn't anymore
I think I've seen this before is this
how not to summon a demon lord is this
rezero Ram is that you I can't tell
anymore the yeast eclairs fried my brain
all I see are the same gaming interfaces
the same medieval towns the same edgy
protagonist think of going that maybe
all of this summer was ISA Kai anime is
this a nice acai is that a nice a guy
what does it all mean
wait a minute I get it now this was all
the test the ISA Kai gods are testing me
Finland saga fire force this on anime of
the season
how can they be when there's no one
being transported to another world this
is never about Vikings or firefighters
or cute girls when the ultimate
evolution of anime was right in front of
our eyes
milf said
[Music]
[Applause]
sankaku Shogun touched in a standard
about me tornado
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed the video
thank you very much this month to Axl
Cloris vdd in your life supreme second
Nicholas Tatum Mike elfin and everyone
else on my patreon for helping to
support me from this month and making
this video possible I know this video is
a bit like the seasoned apologies for
that that's my bad if I get a late start
from these videos then it's kind of like
a snowball effects because there are so
many episodes of animator go through now
that if I'm not on top of it then it
just delays it by a week or two and of
course it really didn't help with the
start of last month being a X and of
course me putting all my resources into
our Kyoto Animation video oh it feels
worth the wait like course I do
as always put a lot of effort to these
videos anyway that's it for me though no
further updates
I've been Gigot and I'll see you all
next time